bonjour je suis Delphine nordvillar je
suis rabbin et auteur et je vais réagir
à des archives de Lina
[Musique]
bonjour vous allez bien très bien est-ce
que vous êtes prêtes à voyager dans les
archives de Lina ouais je trouve ça
excitant intéressant de voir quelle
trace le passé à conserver alors on y va
et on va commencer par votre première
télévision alors elle est un peu
particulière parce qu'en fait ce n'est
pas une archive de vous mais c'est vous
qui faites l'archive et on va entendre
votre voix et on va vous voir un petit
peu enfin surtout vos yeux
la carte du génome humain est presque
complète sa connaissance autorise de
très grands espoirs pour créer les
médicaments de demain explication
Delphine Horvilleur
de la couleur de nos yeux à notre groupe
sanguin nos 30
c'est drôle je me souvenais pas du tout
de ce reportage mais effectivement
j'étais toute jeune journaliste et c'est
le moment où se combinent des moments de
ma vie des les études de médecine et le
journaliste qui viennent se raccrocher
l'un à l'autre mais justement c'est
incroyable comment on passe de
journaliste arabe
en fait j'ai eu l'impression de faire
des c'est vrai des virages souvent les
gens trouvent que j'ai fait des virages
drastiques parce que j'étais étudiante
en médecine je suis devenue journaliste
et je suis devenue rabat ensuite mais je
me rends compte aujourd'hui que tout ce
que j'ai pu chercher dans ces
différentes voies résonne en fait
j'étais toujours dans
intéressé par d'avoir la question de la
transmission et la question de l'écoute
et du narratif en fait ce que j'ai pu
chercher dans la médecine c'est-à-dire
la volonté d'écouter le récit de l'autre
de le traduire d'accompagner c'est ce
que j'ai cherché aussi dans le
journalisme d'une certaine manière et
c'est ce que j'ai fini par trouver de
façon un peu plus précise pour moi dans
le rabina c'est-à-dire c'est une
fonction d'accompagnement
d'écoute d'explication de transmission
on va faire un saut dans le temps pour
s'intéresser à votre au début de votre
vie actuelle on est en 2009 on regarde
votre installation à la synagogue de
Beaugrenelle à Paris France 2 vous
consacrez alors un feuilleton en 5
épisodes
j'arrive officiellement pour repartir en
congé maternité j'espère que d'un départ
temporaire mais qui a mes yeux rend
cette cérémonie d'accueil d'autant plus
symbolique puisque je suis accueillie
ici au moment où je m'apprête à
accueillir un nouvel être et cette
situation est peut-être assez inédite à
l'échelle de l'histoire juive puisque
bizarrement ces derniers siècles les
rabbins ont rarement pris des congés
maternité
ni les textes ni les hommes non de
visage unique c'est de cette idée que
j'aimerais teintée mon rabbinat qui
s'ouvre aujourd'hui être capable
d'accueillir les visages comme on lit un
texte sacré dans le sens reste toujours
à découvrir
finalement je me rends compte que je
continue d'enseigner beaucoup la même
chose ça me rappelle quand j'étais à
l'école rabini qui a un de mes
enseignants qui nous avait dit je crois
pour travailler notre humilité nous
avait dit que dans la vie en tant que
rabbin on a maximum un ou deux sermons à
donner en fait on finit toujours par
délivrer le même enseignement ce qui
éviterait des rabbins et bien évidemment
vrai des prêtres et des imams mais
peut-être de chacun d'entre nous dans
nos fonctions d'enseignement peut-être
qu'on a un discours à donner un
enseignement à apporter au monde voilà
un message à transmettre faut essayer de
trouver le bon mais moi j'ai
l'impression que finalement oui cette
question de la pluralité des langages
elle est très centrale dans dans mon
travail j'y pense souvent aussi
quand je fais face comme on y fait tous
face aujourd'hui à l'intolérance
religieuse au dogmatisme ou
fondamentalisme finalement le propre des
fondamentalistes c'est qu'ils veulent
toujours vous faire croire que le texte
n'a qu'un message et que ce message
c'est celui qui correspond alors agenda
politique à eux ils sont persuadés que
le texte a déjà fini de parler et n'a
plus qu'à enseigner leur dogmatisme leur
étroitesse d'esprit et en fait c'est ça
qu'il faut déconstruire le texte il a
jamais fini de parler et bien sûr qui
peut parler voix de la violence de
l'extrémisme et du fondamentalisme mais
il a aussi beaucoup d'autres choses à
dire et à transmettre des voies
d'ouverture et de tolérance en fait le
texte il peut nous faire grandir où il
peut nous rendre tout petits médiocre et
misérable et parfois même assassin on va
vous montrer deux autres personnages
très important pour vous deux femmes qui
vous ont inspiré donc vous avez été
proche Marceline Loridan et Simone Veil
lorsque vous voyez Marceline Loridon et
avant de passer à la séquence suivante
ça vous rappelle un certain nombre de
choses importantes qui sont passées dans
votre vie et vous êtes restés en contact
étroit
nous avons été déportés ensemble je
pense que c'est une chose suffisamment
dur et après tout qui est absolument pas
utile d'évoquer j'aurais bien aimé
entendre ce tutoiement quand même alors
je peux lui demander si tu vas bien
c'est fou tous les sous-entendus pesant
de cette séquence qui fait semblant
d'être légère mais qui est
incroyablement lourde ce moment où
présentateur dit c'est pas la peine je
sais pas quel terme il utilise c'est pas
la peine de l'évoquer bah si c'est quand
même la peine de l'évoquer c'est à dire
qu'on ça raconte bien le fait que
pendant des dizaines d'années en France
on a été totalement en français dans le
monde on a été totalement incapable ou
en tout cas on n'a pas voulu ou pas pu
évoquer la Shoah la déportation il y
avait ce silence cette chape de plomb
cette incapacité ou non volonté dans
d'en parler et là on leur demande de se
tutoyer comme si de rien n'était mais en
réalité d'ailleurs ce tutoiement et
derrière ses sourires ou c'est rire
qu'elles contiennent il y a tout le
malaise qu'on perçoit d'une France qui
arrive pas encore à parler de son passé
qui arrive pas encore à sortir ces
archives et elle elles vont carnet de
façon extraordinaire la prise de parole
en tout cas pour moi ces deux visages
c'est les visages de la prise de parole
sur ce moment d'histoire pendant des
décennies personne ne parle de ce qui
s'est passé ce drame absolu de la
déportation et de la joie de ce drame
humain qui n'est pas qu'un drame juif
c'est un drame humain et elle elles vont
prendre la parole chacune alors manière
chacune dans leur style alors vous dites
souvent que ces deux femmes cohabitent
en vous mais elle cohabitant moi comme
comme je crois qu'elle cohabite en
chaque femme d'une manière particulière
vous savez pour moi Simone Veil c'est
une femme qui raconte le sens du devoir
d'être à la hauteur de transmettre
avec sérieux avec un signe qui raconte
voilà le sorte de devoir dans lequel
beaucoup de femmes s'inscrivent et qui
pèsent souvent sur nos épaules et de
femmes et de mère et des pauses etc et
puis Marceline au contraire c'est ce
féminin un peu passionné qui aspire à la
liberté à la passion à l'amour et et moi
j'ai souvent l'impression qu'en moi mais
aussi ayant beaucoup de femmes que je
rencontre il y a en permanence un
dialogue intérieur un combat un
arbitrage entre la Simone et la
Marceline qui parle en nous une Simone
qui nous dit attention il faut que tu
sois à la hauteur et une Marceline qui
dit pardon du langage tu peux les
envoyer bouler et suivre ce que tu
ressens ou aimer à la folie alors juste
avant vous avez évoqué la question du
silence ce silence qui a pesé sur la
France qui a pesé sur des familles de
déportés et justement on va écouter
Simone Veil qui avait réalisé un
enregistrement avec nous à Lina en 2006
évoqué cette question du silence on
avait tous le sentiment
qu'on risquait d'être
tous exterminé c'est à ce moment-là et
en tout cas beaucoup sont morts sur les
routes ou dans les trains ensuite
mais qu'il fallait que il y en a qui
rentre et qui raconte ça c'était de venu
une priorité et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple c'est
important et je crois que tous ceux qui
ont témoigné ont dû l'exprimer aussi à
quel point pour nous c'est important de
le dire et en même temps je comprends
très bien que certains n'aient pas pu
parler
je comprendrais bien qu'il n'est pas pu
parler parce que c'est trop douloureux
trop difficile
je crois aussi que certains n'en n'ont
pas parlé du tout à leur famille parce
que ça c'est
on sent très bien que pour nos familles
c'est quelquefois insupportables mais
quand même temps
quand il rencontre d'autres camarades de
déportation à ce moment-là ils parlent
oui
magnifiquement ce qui a été une réalité
tragiquement c'est ce qui a été une
réalité pour beaucoup de survivants
moi je viens d'une famille où on n'a pas
parlé mes grands-parents qui étaient
du côté de ma mère était tous les deux
des rescapés des camps et ils n'ont rien
dit mais mais un mutisme absolu je crois
que tout ce que l'on sait de leur
histoire
c'est des mots
un peu des récit recomposés avec des
éléments tu des choses qui disaient
parfois dans leur sommeil même des noms
qu'il criait dans leur sommeil des voilà
des traumatismes qui a laissé des
éléments et par cette information qu'il
a fallu
reconstituer
et ça a été le cas de beaucoup de
survivants de pas pouvoir dire
moi je me rends compte aujourd'hui que
j'ai été construite
en partie par ce silence je me dis
souvent que si j'écris aujourd'hui si
j'enseigne c'est que d'une certaine
manière j'essaie de combler les vides
les j'essaie vous savez exactement comme
dans les jeux auxquels on joue quand on
est enfant il y a des points et c'est à
nous tirer les traits entre les points
numérotés moi j'ai eu l'impression de
grandir avec un dessin il y avait plein
de points il y a pas de numéro il y
avait juste
des traits qu'il fallait que je retrace
pour que ça dessine une image alors on
continue le voyage dans l'histoire de
France on va rembobiner encore un petit
peu pour vous faire écouter une archive
devenue historique et polémique
jusqu'à leur dispersés
mais qui était resté ce qu'ils avaient
été de tout temps c'est à dire
un peuple d'élite
sur de lui-même
et de
n'en viennent une fois qu'il serait
rassemblée dans le site de son ancienne
grandeur
n’envielle a changé en ambition
et conquérante
les souhaits très émouvants qu'il
formait depuis 19 siècles
l'an prochain à Jérusalem
mythique mythologique légendaire cette
petite phrase de général de Gaulle un
peuple voilà d'élite sur de lui-même
dominateur parfois des résidus
antisémites sont parlées par des gens
qui sont pas du tout antisémites on
pourrait pas accuser des gens moi
j'accuserai pas le général de Gaulle
d'être antisémite mais il y a comme des
résidus de
il y a pas d'autres mots dans le langage
de l'antisémitisme qui voyage dans le
temps qui ressurgit dans des moments de
l'histoire on s'y attend pas
nécessairement on va maintenant quitter
la France pour un pays que vous
connaissez bien vous y étiez d'ailleurs
le 4 novembre 1995
l'assassin vient d'être maîtrisé c'est
l'homme à la chemise bleue plaquée
contre le mur par les policiers
il s'agit d'un Israélien de 27 ans
étudiant en droit dans une université
religieuse Jean Friedman l'organisateur
de la manifestation est un des témoins
de l'assassinat nous accompagner le
Premier ministre sa voiture et surgir à
tirer trois bacs sur lui il est
Bruxelles atteint à la poitrine et à
l'abdomen it's sacrabine est décédé 1h
plus tard sur la table d'opération
Israël est en état de choc spontanément
des israéliens se sont rendus devant
l'hôpital
certains en criant leur colère contre la
droite israélienne
ce meurtre s'est déroulé à l'issue de la
plus grande manifestation pour la paix
organisée à Tel-Aviv depuis 1982
il sera cabine avait pris la parole
répétant que rien n'arrêtera le
processus de paix il faut disait-il que
cesse les guerres pour nous pour
l'avenir pour nos petits-enfants
cette chose du mal des décennies plus
tard
voilà à revoir ou commenter ces images
c'est vrai que j'ai l'impression que
pour moi il y a eu un avant et un après
ce 4 novembre 95 c'est vrai que j'étais
sur cette place
dans cette manifestation pour la paix ce
soir là et
on est parti à la fin de la
manifestation Rabine venait de prendre
la parole il avait chanté un chant qui
est devenu très célèbre rabbini chantait
très faux mais il avait chanté un chant
israélien devenu extrêmement célèbre de
pluie qui s'appelle le chant pour la
paix qui était en plus à posteriori ce
chant était comme un espèce de prophétie
en fait il allait mourir quelques heures
plus tard et il chantait en hébreu cette
chanson qui dit
où est un Yom ne dites pas qu'un jour
viendra mais faites venir ce jour qui
dépend de vous ce jour de la paix mais
est-ce que ceux qui ont assassiné Rabine
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils ont gagné
aujourd'hui
c'est terrible à dire mais oui quand je
vois aujourd'hui les quand je vois
l'actualité en Israël les dernières
élections je me dis que d'une certaine
manière une une idéologie en tout cas
qui nourrissait l'assassin de Rabine
à gagner une bataille effectivement
c'est terrible de se dire que voilà on
est quelques décennies après cette
assassinat et que et que les rêves de
Rabine et les miens sont piétiné on va
parler d'un sujet plus léger maintenant
l'humour quoi que un sujet léger il y en
a qui le prennent quand même assez au
sérieux regardez l'humour juive et bien
en Israël on examine cela d'une manière
extrêmement sérieuse figurez-vous
incongrie sur ce thème sidéraux
actuellement Charles Anderlin et assisté
pour nous
s'amuse pas l'humour juif y est docteur
analysé par des chercheurs venus du
monde entier et ce n'est qu'à la pause
café qu'on peut entendre une bonne
blague juive
qui parle de religion et qui dit moi
toute façon l'au-delà j'y crois pas tout
ça c'est des blagues mais enfin
j'emporterai quand même un slip de
rechange mais toute demande
d'explication se termine en bataille
d'experts
une action exclue la réflexion c'est
grave pas la réflexion l'humour est un
phénomène beaucoup plus et je pense
qu'il faut être assez profondément
névrosée ça c'est mon idée le petit mot
juive les jokes juifs sont presque de
sorte d'interprétation psychanalytique à
découvert après moi ce que vous pensez
oui l'humour juif c'est quelque chose de
très sérieux en fait pour moi si je
devais participer à ce congrès j'ai
jamais t'invité je dirais que le bon jeu
qui repose sur trois piliers une
capacité à rire des mots et du langage
c'est à dire faire des malentendus des
jeux de mots une capacité à se moquer de
soi l'autodérision c'est centrale dans
l'humour juif parfois l'humour juif
c'est des blagues un peu antisémites
mais raconter par des Juifs beaucoup
mieux qu'un antisémite ne les
raconterait et puis le troisième pilier
c'est se moquer de Dieu c'est à dire
qu'une serre une certaine quelque chose
qui serait peut-être jugé comme une
profanation par d'autres religions les
juifs ils ont pas de problème souvent
pas se moquer de du divin à se moquer de
la religion à se moquer des croyances
donc voilà les jeux de mots
l'autodérision et sans prendre un peu au
divin c'est la recette parfaite de
l'humour Juifs
justement en 1983 plus de 3000
catholiques écrivaient une lettre à la
Haute autorité pour dénoncer les
humoristes qui se moquaient des prêtres
et surtout du petit Jésus et on va
écouter la réponse dans des principaux
accusés Pierre Desproges vous avez
décidé à votre tour d'écrire à une haute
autorité je suis indigné moi-même
c'est une lettre ouverte à Monseigneur
Lustiger
chers Seigneur qu'il me soit permis de
m'indigner ici véhément contre les
insupportables attaques portées
régulièrement à la télévision à mon
athéisme militant par vos camarades de
goupillons il est intolérable deux
siècles après la séparation de l'Église
et de l'État dans un pays qui pousse la
laïcité officielle au rang d'institution
nationale que des anti athées hystérique
accaparent l'antenne de la télévision le
dimanche matin avec des émissions
intitulées je cite la messe du dimanche
dans laquelle les minorités athées non
priantes non bigotante et maltifiantes
sont méprisées et bafoués et je pèse mes
mots au profit de grotesque
manifestations incantatoires d'une secte
en robe dont le monothéisme avoué est
une véritable insulte à Darwin aux
religions gréco-romaines et à ma soeur
qui fait bouddhiste dans un bordel de
Kuala Lumpur voilà je précise que
j'envoie par ce même courrier une copie
de cette lettre à Dieu et que ça va
chier
la mise en scène de l'archive parce que
il y a ce cochon en premier plan et la
femme nue à l'arrière donc il est
vraiment enveloppé d'un univers
une pensée sur la transgression je ne
sais pas mais c'est une bonne gare en
fait sa réponse est
assez parfaite qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
dire à ça effectivement on a la chance
je crois de vivre dans un pays où il y a
pas d'accusation de blasphème où on peut
parfois et souvent on doit se moquer des
croyances et moi c'est vrai je dis
souvent que j'ai du mal à croire que
Dieu soit
si petit que il se vexe d'une blague si
Dieu est grand alors a priori grand
aussi doit être son sens de l'humour
vous avez aussi écrit sur le corps
féminin le corps des femmes et en 1975
Agnès Varda posait son regard sur le
corps des femmes
en critique c'est moi que l'on achète
c'est moi que l'on commande par
téléphone c'est moi que l'on paye par
chaque ou en espèces c'est moi que l'on
offre en pâture au désir des hommes
continuent comme ça plein toi bientôt tu
cesseras de nous plaire la tête que tu
feras si aucun homme ne désire moi j'ai
assez d'amour en moi pour que tu me
désires sans que je me déguise en
réclame
au risque de vous déplaire et de rompre
avec certains d'entre vous messieurs les
pères les maris les amants les patrons
les mecs et les copains nous les femmes
on a pris en main notre évolution et si
vous avez encore besoin de femmes et
d'amour c'est vous qui allez être obligé
de changer vos habitudes et quelques-uns
de vos goûts
ça date de quelle année ça c'est fou
cette alors ça c'est 1975 c'est
extraordinaire on sent qu'un virage sa
mort mais qui n'est pas encore
complètement là moi souvent j'utilise
cette image cette métaphore de de la
règle du pion aux échecs vous savez
quand on joue aux échecs on sait que le
pion il avance et il pourra pas reculer
sur l'échiquier et je dis souvent que
pour moi les droits des femmes c'est le
contraire c'est le contraire de la loi
du pion aux échecs vous avancez mais en
permanence ça recule c'est jamais jamais
un acquis regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec le droit à l'intérieur
de son volontaire de grossesse aux
États-Unis ce qui se passe avec les
droits des femmes encore dans tellement
d'endroits dans le monde on croit que
c'est gagné et en fait pas du tout le
point commun entre toujours les la
menace qui pèse sur les femmes et le
droit des femmes c'est que les sociétés
ne parviennent pas à accepter que le
corps des femmes leur appartient c'est
comme si toujours il y avait ce résidu
en nous ancestral qui veut que le corps
d'une femme lui appartiennent pas
vraiment qu'elle appartiennent à sa
famille à ses enfants à sa fonction
maternelle ou d'épousailles ou à la
société ou et c'est toujours très
compliqué pour les femmes de gagner une
propriété sur leur corps et ça bien sûr
c'est présent dans les récits et c'est
présent dans toute notre traditions
religieuses les femmes qui doivent
couvrir leurs chevelure couvrir des
parties de leur corps ne pas les exhiber
ne pas prendre la parole tout ça c'est
lié à une peur du féminin à une peur du
savoir féminin pas seulement du corps
féminin on a peur des sorcières parce
que on suppose que les femmes détiennent
un pouvoir particulier et tous ces
récits ancestraux on peut rigoler on
peut plaisanter on peut dire que c'est
des vieilles histoires mais en réalité
ça continue de d'habiter nos
inconscients et nos sociétés et c'est un
combat permanent de réinterprétation
maintenant on arrive à une séquence
qu'on aime beaucoup on va vous demander
de choisir la personne qui va vous poser
une question alors vous avez le choix
entre Daniel Gilbert Denise Glaser Henri
Chapier et Jacques Chancel
Daniel Gilbert choisit Daniel Gibert
parce que d'abord c'est super cueillez
des femmes intervieweuses pendant
longtemps été que des hommes elle a
marqué quand même sa génération elle
était là voilà les après-midi avec des
questions parfois surréalistes pour ses
invités donc j'aurais adoré être
interviewé par Daniel Gilbert et je dois
dire aussi que sa coiffure me passionne
me fascine moi avec mes cheveux bouclés
j'ai aucune chance de pouvoir faire un
brushing à la Daniel Gilbert un jour
dans ma vie vous pouvez tendre vers une
façon de décoller à l'actualité mais
quelquefois il y a des pièges non oui
si je comprends bien la question Daniel
que vous me posez c'est que on veut
tendre à réagir l'actualité mais parfois
il y a des pièges ouais il y a toujours
des pièges parce que quand on réagit
seulement à l'actualité et qu'on est ce
qu'on dirait le nez dans le guidon à
regarder uniquement l'histoire par le
petit bout de la lorgnette ce qui se
passe en ce moment on oublie d'élargir
la focale se dire qu'en fait
on peut jamais comprendre le monde
aujourd'hui si on n'a pas un peu une
connaissance de ce qui s'est passé avant
si on n'est pas suffisamment
héritier des mondes passés c'est
sûrement aussi pour ça qu'on a besoin
des archives